[Music]
this is this is a huge game right now of
Pi right perspective will solve
everyone's anxiety you got your
perspective morning everybody and
welcome to another episode of tea with
Gary B on this beautiful Friday March
27th I am your host Gary Vaynerchuk this
is my tea party and we are doing a ton
of Q&A today to recap if you're just
joining we've started this I think on
Tuesday we didn't do Monday did we
Dustin did awesome so uh actually we've
done this all week and we're really
enjoying it tons of great questions and
answers a lot of great engagement not a
lot of bells and whistles this new zoom
background is the most most Bell or
whistle that we brought to the table but
very in-depth detailed answers to
business questions I'm going to try to
get some more today Dustin do we have
the first person kind of in the queue
awesome Chris how are you my friend hey
I'm doing great how are you Gary
well where are you from I'm from
Minnesota fantastic
what can I help you don't a little bit
of a little first off gratitude thank
you for having me on
much appreciated I'm a principal of a
k-12 school in in Minnesota here and
with the we have now have a shelter in
place our students haven't been in
school for quite a while now one of the
things that I'm fielding and I'm doing
my best to to support them our seniors
who won't be having a graduation won't
be having would be actually our first
prom in school history you know some of
those things and you know I I know I
know kind of what your advice might be
and I know what I've been telling them
what what more would you provide them
what would you what would you say to
them what you are Chris what I'm sure
you're doing and and it's why you said I
know what your advice is you know
obviously you're going to go down the
empathy and the compassion
perspective path right percent good you
go down those three I would say the the
final piece of the equation and maybe
the value out of this call is innovation
you know one could one could argue that
through live streaming and things of
that nature you could have a virtual
prom you could have a virtual graduation
it would take a lot of planning by you
and the superintendent teachers
volunteers parents and students right
but but besides the hey look
thank God we're alive and hey maybe we
can consider doing something in the
summer if some of you want to do it
before you guys go to college you could
do something fun and you know what I
love about innovation like my head goes
to so many different ideas I'm like you
know would it be cool to after you do
all of next year's classes graduation as
many seniors as wanted to come back to
walk whenever one of the most hilarious
things of all times would be a virtual
prom and you know I think some people
would get a laugh out of that dressing
up at home and be virtual with their
date and thinks that nature you're gonna
DJ to come in but it's innovation right
like you could you your school could
reach out to 50 famous Instagram DJs you
know all of them are looking to do stuff
right now one of them says yes all of a
sudden everybody it's hyped because they
have one of the most famous DJs in the
world
DJing virtual prom so I think besides
the things that probably you and I are
connected on based on me hearing you say
I know what you're gonna kind of say I
need your vibe I think innovation is the
final piece of the equation and that is
a macro sentence for everybody this is
this is a huge game right now of Pi
right perspective will solve everyone's
anxiety everyone's right as long as
somebody in your family does not die
from coronavirus this is a blessing no
matter even if you lose your business or
your job in the macro of your entire
life if you see if you see that and you
start innovating that the second part of
PI innovating this is gonna be an
incredible month of innovation where in
20 years you'll hear over dinner
somebody telling you that their
happiness whether in a personal
relationship whether in a business
whether in a career happened during the
two months of downtime during Corona on
my perspective on this
situation is that it's it's really
disrupting education and I believe it's
in a positive way right now
we're teachers our teachers have had two
weeks to plan for students working on
distance learning and they're planning
for my growth we're looking at macro you
know what's it going to look like down
down the road and and how can we
leverage this situation and the
knowledge that we gain from this to
change education I mean Gary I've seen
I've seen your guard I know I know it
was hey you know I get it man
I know it wasn't great you know and and
I guess one of the other questions you
know as we as we look into more of the
online platform and supporting the
distance learning I think about what
what can we do to support reach out and
support our kids with mental health and
you know all of that stuff and you know
what what else can we bring but also
taking it from an individual perspective
you know so like I think back you know
even looking at your report card what
did you what did you need that you
didn't get as as a middle and high
school high school kid what would have
the trip turns out you you ended up just
fine you know what I needed
what do your points whatever I needed
and there was a couple teachers along
the way that did dig in in in humanity
right you're a nice kid Gary this is
obviously you know that kind of stuff
what what they didn't have the
flexibility to do was curriculum me
individually right and I have empathy
for that you know what I needed to be
doing in you know freshman year let me
tell you why there was no A's besides
Jim the other a would have been the
history of advertising right if I was in
class being taught why New Coke failed
right I mean I would have clowned the
valedictorian right sure right and so
that's you know that that well my school
is small enough that we've added an
additional class that we call real world
ready where they're talking about taxes
they're they're doing the I love the
character development stuff they're
doing financials where's Dave Dave
Ramsey program you know all of that
stuff that's what quickly by bridge into
other areas Chris let's make a deal here
next year next year's correct
send me an email right now Christa
principal of Minnesota its Gary at
vaynermedia
I'd love to come in and give a you know
a 45 minute however long the classes
lecture on real world next year on me as
a little added bonus that would be
awesome a stunt free free inspirational
and practical talks uh looking on
Twitter right now Caleb white Caleb
Whittle excuse me I'm retweeting you for
any newcomers to tea with Gary
excuse me tea with Gary B if you take a
screenshot of this and tweet it with a
link to the Facebook live and say join
us I will retweet or follow you Brandon
Baker gets a retweet the MZ family gets
a retweet
Shirou gets a retweet I'll be right with
you Erica just giving that some retweets
to James T to Robin Devin Alexander gets
a retweet Jace Dean gets a retweet
stevehopkins I'm gonna give a follow
boom stevehopkins gets a follow
Nixie and erica is with us
how are you Erica I'm doing well how are
you very well I want to say thank you so
much for doing this it's been a part of
my morning routine so it's just super
awesome husband it has and I want to
thank team Gary Vee for just putting it
together it's just uh just watching you
like work so hard just to give back in a
time where you know people are lost and
I mean I'm fortunate enough to work some
home so you know I don't have to worry
about that but you know it's just to
watch something like this is amazing
thank you okay my question is I'm a
creative person so I'm an industrial
designer that's what I do for work I do
engineering drawings for displays to
build them but on the side I feel like
I'm a jack-of-all-trades and I'm trying
to figure out how to put everything
together what I love doing graphics like
that's my poster on me oh my god [ __ ]
that pic by the way thank you it's so
it's actually I'm so damn it I'm so
pissed to myself I was literally about
to say something and we got right into
it
how much I liked it that's so well done
Erica thank you I'm just super super
hard on myself when it comes to like
doing things and I just don't think I'm
good enough so that really prohibits me
from putting a lot of stuff that I do
out there and do you think it comes from
parenting or environment or DNA I don't
tell you my parents are great they're
super supportive my mom my sisters
everybody's great on that end I think
I'm just super hard on myself let's try
to dig for four more so uh like you
don't deal well with feedback like if
somebody said that poster is not like
like technically sound or I don't like
it does that hurt you or know it hurts
but then they look at okay well can I do
it better or was that just their opinion
right and I and I think if you could be
I think that's smart now if I if you
broke down a hundred percent of the
energy typically on can I do it better
was that good feedback or is that just
their opinion breakdown a hundred
percent of energy do you think it's
twenty eighty fifty fifty a hundred zero
like give me yeah I mean I think it's
probably like maybe eighty percent me
not thinking I'm good enough then and
then twenty percent whether I take their
opinion is valid because it's more about
me less about less yeah so that's an
interesting insight because for me it's
like 98 two you know and I'm trying to
think about what does that mean what is
the Delta between me when people give me
feedback it's ninety what's your
thinking okay I change they're both the
same its underscore made by Erica nice
one okay underscore made by Erica
everybody who's watching right now Oh
God
yep go on Twitter or go to Erica's
latest Instagram post and underscore
made by Erica if you are the kind of
person that sees a poster like that and
thinks it's a hundred dollar poster you
know that style may be a doom one
because that is a celebrity just just
let her know you're one of those people
underscore made by Erica on Twitter and
Instagram let this amazingly talented
young woman know that you and don't go
there let's not be like a nice community
and go there if you're gonna do that
just go and say hey girl keep going but
if you're the kind of person that would
buy a poster like that especially if
signed by her
1 to 100 400 bucks or so just let her
know Erica I can tell you right now if
you're capable making that poster you're
capable of making $100,000 a year
minimum minimum selling [ __ ] posters
you make awesome and when I say minimum
you can become you could make a million
dollars here
that thought is scary but and then I
guess in a good way
okay that's a really good poster I know
I'm just so hard on myself I mean I
really like it I'm not gonna say that I
don't like it but I just yet even like
share that it's like a big deal I guess
yeah cuz you're insecure
yeah oh yeah I don't want you to be
which is why I'm trying to figure out
why and and he's a lot of people have a
ton of great parents who are loving and
sweet but they told them not to take
risk mm-hmm because they came from tough
situations or they don't have the DNA of
a risk-taker right I think I think
that's part of it could be you know I
think yeah definitely that that's a good
part you know part of it I mean I went
to school for graphic design and
industrial design so that was a little
bit of a departure but that was a way
where I can combine my graphics but
still find a job I get it the good news
is the internet came along in our
lifetime America and you can do that job
and start building up me by Erica and
build a business a real one one
Erica I'm telling right now I want you
to email me Gary at vaynermedia I want
to Commission you to make samosas for me
for my office Wow okay I really I'm not
kidding I'm a nice guy and I do things
but I take a lot of calls and I wouldn't
say this like I actually like that kind
of style mm-hmm thank you appreciate I
appreciate it so much
there's no idea listen America you have
to take my my very nice words right now
and not hear them okay and you and you
have to take people that say you suck
and not hear them once you can't hear is
the day you start to live
absolutely thank you so much like I just
yeah just please use the serendipity of
the coronavirus leading to me having
time to leading to this moment take take
that in take in this moment and use that
in three days when the energy of this
call is not here it with you anymore
mm-hm and and you start feeling that
insecurity you're about to get 87 great
comments 120 great comments and one
person might say yeah you ain't that
much [ __ ] wait till I talk to Gary B
he'll see I'm better and if you decide
to focus on that versus the 87 good
you're gonna still be bright back to the
same place you have to not hear the good
comments you have to not hear the bad
comments you have to live in a [ __ ]
cocoon like I do
mmm-hmm turn it out you know you know
why why cuz it doesn't matter true it
did all those opinions of people on your
relationships your looks your school
your work your creativity did all those
opinions matter if yesterday you picked
up Corona and died in a week no good
yeah yeah you're right whose opinion has
value why no I know and I listen to you
all the time and yeah I mean like
everybody you know when is the point
where it sinks in and and the key is I
think what really works for me is I'm
saying that to myself every second that
I breathe it not not occasionally or
when I need it and I'm trying to figure
out what that means and how do I get
that across right you know one of the
other things I just realized it just hit
me do you know one of the reasons I
don't hear anybody is I'm too
compassionate and empathetic that for
them knowing that they have their own
life experiences that led them to a
positive or a negative comment almost
every single person almost every single
person that leaves a negative comment to
another human being whether virtually or
in real life is deeply hurting inside
mm-hmm
yeah now and I I definitely hear that
like I definitely understand that
there's more than just a comment good or
bad you know
and people like Oracle they're just
jealous of your skills and I'm like
let's not even make let's not even
demonize these people that are trying to
hurt us
let's be compassionate to them right
compassion is missing when somebody says
you're supposed there's a piece of [ __ ]
I'm compassionate like man this luck in
person stumbled on my Instagram account
and decided to waste a minute trying to
tear me down they must be in such an
awful place right now that's true
absolutely I mean this yeah I mean I
definitely see things that way I guess
it's just different when it comes to
myself personally you know that means
you don't see it differently
Wow yeah that that's what I mean that
means you understand the theory but
you're not living it right oh thank you
thank you very well yeah I just there's
not enough thanks in the world for just
everything you do and you gives
everybody and for this call like there's
so much value it's not even funny like
and I just really appreciate how the
circumspect aching the best out of a
situation correct so thank you so much
Rock America email me Facebook we are
back thank you so much for waiting for
the last hour I was on Instagram Live
for the last hour doing tea with Gary
Vee now we're back on Facebook and Tim
thank you so much for icing the kicker
waiting it out started for the technical
difficulties but we improvised Tim were
you watching on uh on Instagram or you
just kind of wing it yeah yeah like two
phones and two computers here so what
cancer free Willie a little bit of
background here Solis yeah so you out
usually asked went how did you when you
start listening I'm we're about the same
vintage here so I I remember back when
my daughter was first born walking
around listening to diggnation
on podcast yeah mm course and like on
library I used to watch that back then
2006 but here's the crazy thing so I'm
gonna be pretty vulnerable in this cloud
because maybe it's less for me and maybe
what other people can get out of this
I remember going back then don't I
really want to start a podcast and I'm
like it's too [ __ ] late
what the yeah it seriously so like same
thing a Twitter I've been on Twitter
forever barely do anything you know but
uh now so so there's two ways to look in
my current situation right like a
defensive frame I'm going through a
divorce right now and and you know my
Jeff I was the chief operating officer
is pretty - company and then that's all
changed right so on the other flip side
it's a blank slate and it's not really
where I want to be anyway in terms of
like in terms of corporate America or
stuff like that I'm like I could give
you [ __ ] about the title I didn't care
you know but it's like this is what I'm
supposed to be doing and so we're in
that weird border right where we're
we're not you know we're too old to be
Millennials or they can't have that kind
of thing but we're and you know my
parents are great but they they were
very much like you know this is this is
the path you should choose and like you
know go to schools I have multiple
college degrees and all that stuff but
never felt right so now I'm trying to
figure out what do I want to do so like
weird [ __ ] I I started baking sourdough
bread when I moved into my partner some
nights ago and actually last night I
sold my first two left and I don't even
necessarily be a baker what I'd rather
do is me like be an Instagram talking
about that you know we're like using
that as one of the things not just I
guess so
yeah and that's probably why I've always
struggled not be laid off five times so
I think that's good yes I actually think
that's good I think that's a interesting
data point it means that you aren't
capable of completely conforming that's
that's my observation so that I'm glad
that you gave that confirmation that's
good that's good
keep going
yeah I mean so that's just been my thing
right now is like what you know like
hobbies let's talk about it obviously
yeah you just beat me to it going
through a divorce without knowing how
you saved or what your actual situation
is how much freedom financially do you
have to be able to have the ability to
completely be creative and try to figure
this out or how quickly do you need to
make a meaningful enough income to
fulfill your obligations yes so like I
spent you know the last few months kind
of burning through a lot of that right
and so and I didn't look this is a
process to me last year if you had me on
this I was not this guy and honestly
part of this uh you want to come therapy
whatever just getting on here because
I'm like a lot of things about myself
and I've been working a really hard so
just getting out in here and like
realizing that there's four or five ten
whatever how many thousands of people
watching this is like you know I'm
sweating a little bit like I also went
down on me like I like to you know look
understood so it's like this magician
performer inside of me that wants to
like get out but then there's other cars
it's no you gotta go sit at a desk job
no I don't you know so answer your
question it's interesting like I've got
I actually just picked up some
consulting work that should be able so
I'll be able to have flexibility in my
schedule probably be able to float the
bills for a little bit and that's like
that's the goal right so do you want it
do you do you want to build a personal
brand around your your truth like the
seven to nine things you like do you
want you want to do you want to document
do you want to document a journey like
the post divorced man you know starring
Tim and it's just kind of like the
documentation of you finding your thing
which I've always thought is a huge
opportunity because there's nothing
easier you know everyone's like what do
I make and I'm like the truth you make
the truth you literally some days it's
just you in front of the camera like
this other days you setup your you know
you know your you know whatever your
video recording it seems like you're
technically savvy enough with two
computers in the two iPhones so like
maybe some so so maybe the Tuesday blog
and
test is you just crying and saying why
you're still not over the divorce or
you're crying got a happiness that
you're ready to be happy and whatever
whatever the truth is and then Wednesday
it might be the making of the sourdough
and then Thursday it might be you
showing the picture of you selling two
loaves and you saying look this is
really like necessarily the business I
want to build but I like this and you
know what I'm gonna fly a kite tomorrow
so like I think the documentation that
the process has the potential to make
them my biggest theory is if you
document the journey of finding the
thing that when you find the thing you
now have tens of thousands thousands
hundreds for hundreds of thousands and
for a very small group millions of
people that are that have been so
invested in the journey that when you
open up your bike shop you [ __ ] crush
no I'm not and I think one of the things
I've come to the conclusion up with me
is I don't know that there's a thing or
that today there shouldn't be like I
could write so that's just not my she's
not a person now that's why I can easily
in the sourdough reason I'm selling is
because people like this is [ __ ]
amazing bread why aren't you selling
this I'm like I don't know I just
started started doing this on the side
as later you gotta be short yeah you got
to make sure that that it doesn't become
the desk job right exactly exactly a
nice when you are on the word Tim or Tim
I apologize for interrupting or that's
good you love it
for nine months and when it becomes a
desk job you go into selling kite kits
that's what I do right I just do [ __ ]
I'm a little I don't want to missed a
lot of the documenting the journey so
far all you're doing now is saying
you're too old to do a podcast just like
with diggnation
[ __ ] the part that you miss the
documentation you got fifty more years
of documenting yeah
you can't dwell you have to do it well
then you missed all that yeah this
episode one of the new documentation
starting tomorrow is just a recap of
everything we've all missed and I think
I think part of me is just so you know
why haven't I done this before right and
that's the core issue that I'm still
trying to get to the bottom of this like
that then that fear putting yourself out
there right like everybody on this call
probably knows that gets that a lot of
people I mean you get it but you you
bust through it you know like your path
and my past in 2005 took two different
things you know and that's okay here's
here's a good news brother in 2005 and
you and I took different paths I got
good news for you
tomorrow's our our patch take different
paths in 2020 like to it were young no
yeah we're young we obviously you know
we got some gray hairs now that we don't
have those days but brother we're
[ __ ] yeah do you know how you have
any 62 year old friends I mean that do
you have any 62 year old friends yeah
yeah go like go FaceTime them and go out
dinner with them as soon as this is over
or young yeah I don't know what to tell
you dude do you remember 20 years ago
how you know how young you fell 20 years
ago it's just this you know just I mean
like it's funny because I feel like I'm
talking to you and I don't realize that
there's 10,000 people who watching this
but like but then like me putting up me
putting up an Instagram thing and being
like it's a [ __ ] up man it's just I
guess he's got a doing getting dumped
right but it's like that's three were
you so the executive thing I built up
you know were you scared to kiss girls
yeah me too but then you eventually did
it and then it became awesome yeah sure
were you scared to ride a bike
no I don't think so I was like I'm a
[ __ ] skinned my knee like I'm so
[ __ ] scared of skating my knee and
then I started riding a bike what about
the first time you post a concert that
came different that came easy just like
there's some people here's the good news
but but that but for a lot of people
posting content is the scary thing like
I was with bike but for them they're
like he was scared of write a Viking
scooter like you know that was there you
know but we got through it
we got through it
it's all fake yeah that's all the
boogeyman it's wise it's why I said [ __ ]
you devil on the Instagram line and then
you pushes a dick like and you know it's
funny I know on the other end there's
like some 68 year old grandma from
Mexico's like oh my god no not Diablo
he's in trouble he's gonna die no no
it's [ __ ] fake so many things fake
you know so many [ __ ] things are fake
so many the visions your parents had was
fake like isn't about being
ultra-conservative that's fake no it
hasn't really worked out for me either
right like I tried to do the right thing
good news the good news that's on you
that's what exactly yeah I could see it
as long as you don't put that on your
parents as long as ID
exactly so now good news all right all
right brother give me some good homework
make Greek make honestly I think
listening to the diggnation thing just
kind of listening I think I I think
listen it's it's proven in the Veda one
of the greatest things that ever came
out of my mouth was document don't
create and I think I I think you should
start documenting I think tomorrow
should be episode 1 comic book number
one first album where you we literally
talk like this and recap us completely I
was a boy that born in Denver you know
like like give us just put it all like
done all all all all the platforms which
I already can tell you know what to do
so yes and then the next day you're like
all right here it is we're documenting
the journey today's you know day 21 of
the coronavirus I've been baking the
spread like I told you about yesterday
I'm gonna bake a [ __ ] cookie see what
happens so here we go putting up the
phone and then that's your seven-minute
YouTube video you making a [ __ ]
chocolate-chip cookie take care let's
keep it going Dustin if you're watching
right now on Facebook please take a
photo and post it on on Twitter and say
hi and like to follow and retweet some
of you and that would be fun
my man what's good Ricky oh what's up
Gary
by the way they they want to say hi hi
ladies hi how are you guys hi guys man
Ariel how are you Ricky and Ariel say hi
all right they they know about you
because you know I've been hearing you
for years years thank you since you
started as a scary B and I've been just
trying to just you know say hi I'm
nervous right now
no worries man I'm super flattered to be
on with you bro Oh quick just backstory
man I used to work for a school district
you know I was getting rate where you're
complacent there I guess just God you
know the system there and yeah my hobby
was are my passion is not I should say
but business too so once I came across
your content you you gave me that
permission literally man that's the only
way I can explain it you know I mean
like it's Ricky thank you so much bro
it's it's I genuinely believe that I'm a
permission practitioner like um the
reason I go after parents the system
school other things is because for
hundreds of millions that is the thing
that's keeping them in the box and I
want to be the person they point you to
blame or the shield like I'm trying to
give people the ear cover the permission
to go you don't even know how you saying
that how much that means to me yeah she
also loves your content to so man yeah
like I said you gave me that permission
somehow through your content you know
unite here I hear everybody asking you
questions so I so I'm nervous man I'm
not leaving I knew I was gonna leave it
and I even recorded during the the sign
now said it's your teeth
yeah they're like you're constantly
innovating and even in in troubled times
even through technology here in in Ricky
and thank you for seeing it I'm at my
best when it's the worst now no sound no
problem because I'm not scared
Ricky cuz I'm not [ __ ] scared I mean
so yeah so to be sure man I know a lot
of people want to get in and whatever
but uh you give me a permission to just
don't regret you know so what I did is I
quit the job
I literally quit a stable government job
you know for the for school district I
started working my brother he has our
event business called 909 jumpers and I
work with him and I helped him build it
up more branding because I do a lot of
graphic design I'm an artist you know
and we basically grinded dirt you know
how you said for three years man I just
helped him yeah he's good at operations
I was good at marketing we pushed it
push to push they then I got to a point
where I was able to open up my own
tattoo studio and this is the tattoo
studio here shamelessly I got Boehner
Sports ID and so you know now at the
point where it's everything is halted
you know I mean yeah yeah because I'm
most event rental business and pretty
much one on one person yeah so I mean I
understand what you're gonna say gonna
just build content right now you know
you answer it's the really certainly you
know for example I I think this is right
I'm sorry I don't know tattoo culture
well enough but I'm not an idiot you
draw it out and then you tattoo it right
yeah I know you have to document that
bro yeah you have to you have to post a
tattoo drawing every single day on every
platform
okay yeah you also have to sell stuff
Saturday yeah I'm looking at my my house
what I can sell you have to do that it's
just it's a nice thing to do you'll
clean up we all need to have less [ __ ]
and clutter anyway you're gonna also
hone your marketing skills you're gonna
do something on craigslist and ebay that
then is gonna matter for your tattoo
business in september because you
learned something about copy or creative
that led to the sale of a bike or that
Apple screen in the background or a book
up there or whatever that's a big deal
yeah I appreciate that
that's very what about LinkedIn have you
started creating not yet right okay and
then I just it's that first you know
learning stage and I'm like ah I'll get
back to it but you know what I got a lot
of time right now I'm gonna get back
down to it listen to me I know what
you're gonna say Gary make content right
is no different than a doctor saying eat
healthy and exercise I know that
everybody watching right now knows what
I'm gonna say I'm [ __ ] trying to get
[ __ ] to do you I'm you know I'm
hoping through one on one this was our
moment and that makes you do I'm hoping
somebody else's name who's you know
Sammy Gonzalez who sees himself in you
right now in El Paso Texas like [ __ ] it
I'm just like Ricky I'm gonna do so that
all of a sudden two people are gonna do
from this video step by step by step by
step by step by step you understand
brother listen to me if you are not
posting tattoo content on Facebook
Twitter Instagram YouTube snapchat
LinkedIn every day multiple times a day
tick-tock
then you're [ __ ] up well you know
what I did I did start a live class with
my kids because you don't where I'm home
and I'm like whoa I have like so many
clients in the tattoo industry and my
company our parents and then in the in
the event rental their parents as well
so I figured they're home I'd like to
draw less drew and we did one session
when was it Monday we did one session
left class you know and we basically
filmed a live on Instagram and and we
just started drawing a Mickey Mouse
character you know and I feel
here the parents are gonna show it to
their kids and you know that brings me
balanced and I can't connect to them
when I want but you know that's what I
cannot for right now you know I love it
now if you saw that free deck that I put
out how to make 64 pieces of content or
to gather the content model now that
video you need to put into post edit
learn how to do it and make 12 pieces of
content from it not just one
riki the games about volume
yeah volume and when artists here volume
they think quantity instead of quality
and it [ __ ] them up man man
it is quantity for years I've been
following you it means a lot made my day
thank you brother take care you to the
family talk you see guys try to sneak a
couple more in here before we bounce out
see Trevor Trevor Agnew you get a
retweet
thank you for posting that photo
you
creepers in the building hello hi how
are you
I'm did you - Malvika mal di ka hai
Malvika hi were you from so I'm from
India but I'm in Virginia right now in
the u.s. yeah I'm so excited that we
could get this call on my family's
watching on like I love it in India big
shout out I also wanted to show you this
picture that I made that was you make
that was incredible thank you for that I
thank so talented what can I help you
with um so right now I I did my
undergrad in the US and I'm on a
one-year visa in the US that ends in
September and I plan to go back and help
my aunt on her fashion business she's an
entrepreneur and she's done amazing work
like Sally works for Facebook and I'm
really excited to do it but then I also
get a lot of advice for people tell me
that like this is the time till I
probably work for like a big company and
get more exposure to like things like
growth and things like that but I feel
in my gut and this is what I want to do
and I'm just so excited for it and like
the only model that I have to like do
all like this is based on like what
you're doing so like I have that
structured that won't but like and I
believe in it but like it's also like
just you know I wanted your perspective
on that talk it through talk it's real I
understand what what uh what are you
actually asking at the end there where
you say you know I have your model in
mind
are you questioning if you can execute
against it are you questioning what else
you could be doing what other angles
like how does that manifest in your
brain um so I mean I am dedicated to
doing this so like maybe the next ten
years of my life but this stuff like you
know it's like oh well I have the money
like I live with my fam family like I'm
45 we're doing that as well like it all
works awesome in the end but like I do
my dad like invested all this money to
bring me to the u.s. like he'd say and I
do feel that pressure but at the same
time I feel like this is he is he is he
concerned about you going into the
business with your head he's very
supportive and with me but he also
worries that like I don't know he
feeling about like a small in like a
small business this is a large one and
Apple with that and like I've been
sending him your videos I'm like this is
what he said like he said it's fine
really I think I have a lot of empathy
and a lot of compassion and a lot of
respect for your dad and I understand I
really do I think the thing that I keep
trying to tell children especially from
India and China and Russia because
there's so many similarities with you
know different cultures is your father
loves you and at the end so what he's
worried about is he and his soul thinks
that the big business is safer and he
wants to protect you and he think he
also probably thinks like we've also
made this investment in your education
it seems practical and right to him
unfortunately for you and so many people
in India in Asia in parts of Europe
unfortunately so many of those people
don't want to be engineers or doctors or
lawyers and and it leads to incredible
unhappiness and I remind parents to look
at other parents who have you know who
are older 20 30 years ahead and I go
look look at them that's your family and
that 43 year old woman resents her
parents and they don't have a good
relationship mm-hm and it's not good and
so here's what I would tell you couple
things number one this is why youth is
so incredible you can go work for your
aunt spend eight years on it and at the
end of the day god forbid it's a quote
unquote failure right yeah hey it's not
a failure because you're gonna learn so
much more in a small entrepreneurial
business then you'll ever learn in a big
corporation so much more number two it's
not a failure because you're gonna be
uncomfortably young uncomfortably young
and you will have our degree and you'll
have your own street smarts and your
conviction and you can always get a job
at a big company big companies are
always interested in hiring because they
make they make profit by having more
people if they know how to run their
business so I think it's more I would
argue if you and your
if I and your dad became friendly we
were having tea Russians and Indians
love to have and we were taught okay I
would say to him father interestingly
enough I would argue that it's more
practical for her to go into the startup
with the aunt than it is for her to go
into a big company that big companies
are in full control and that can lead to
her getting let go during the
coronavirus versus navigating plus let's
look at her face she clearly has the
passion and conviction to give it a try
I actually think that I believe in that
I believe in that truth he's listening
right now so he and and and father for
like you know like I you can't imagine
how much respect you know I'm the
byproduct of immigrant parents
hard-working parents loving parents I
have so much empathy and compassion for
parents I never a lot of times I say
[ __ ] what your mom thinks it's not
because I don't have compassion for the
mother it's because I'm trying to give
freedom for the child so that the mother
and the child the father a child can
have a great relationship long term I
watched so many parents do to their
children what their parents did to them
and they should know better because they
know they didn't like it when their
parents did it and money is not money is
not happiness happiness is happiness and
we do not need things we do not need a
lot of things small homes and not and
food is more than enough and so always
chase happier it's especially to youth
because it's practical to get a job at
2829 because many corporations the way
the world's going are gonna actually
look at people that did entrepreneurship
and SMB poor no corporation not a
company that your father would want you
to go into now in nine years if it fails
is more likely to hire you not because
you went to a competitor for nine years
on your resume but because you were
entrepreneurial because the internet is
forcing entrepreneurship to be a more
important variable within corporations
that's awesome I want to squeeze in one
more thing before I have to leave
I mean so four days before the
internship deadline for your internship
I thought about the one thing
wanna do before I leave the u.s. and
there's nothing more amazing to me than
working for you so I just want to tell
you about what I did to make that happen
so I booked tickets to unify Las Vegas
which was supposed to happen today
coincidentally but it's also really
weird that I'm speaking to you right now
the second thing I did was like hey des
like 64 pieces of content and four days
challenge for myself before the deadline
and I knocked it out I finished it I
made a second video about it and like
share it all over my Instagram and I
emailed a lot I liked annoyed like
Brandon and Jed at all of them on the in
DMS they were really have to reply to me
you know could fight him by emails
although you're amazing and like the
main point that I'm gonna tell you from
that was that the process itself was so
amazing to me like I got so addicted to
that that like I started my own weekly
playlist on my other account because I
loved it so much and the second thing is
like I just know how much your employees
mean to you and it makes complete sense
to me so if it doesn't work out it's
fine but I just want to tell you that
like I haven't good work and if I could
possibly work for free at any point like
what I mean I mean you know right right
now so I mean email let me look at it
it's Gary at vaynermedia I'll do that
I'm really proud of you you are an
incredible young woman I'm a big buyer
of you I couldn't think of a better way
to NT with Gary be on this beautiful
Friday I'm debating going on tomorrow
the team I was asking if this one person
in I think you're gonna really like this
person hey Dustin we're gonna have to do
this person on tomorrow because I have
to do something with my kids and I love
everybody tea with Gary B I hope you
enjoyed it it was an interesting day
Facebook live that Instagram Facebook
Dustin thank you for persevering thank
you for everybody I love you guys so
much a couple things one please share
this a lot more people tomorrow we'll
update you guys later tonight what time
tomorrow if tomorrow what time tomorrow
if tomorrow tomorrow might be wine with
Gary Vaynerchuk we'll figure it out but
definitely back Monday morning and very
likely I'll see you over the weekend I
love you guys all so much please go
flash 10,000 of your watching
clashed Twitter right now Gary Vee and
tell me what you thought about today's
episode and I love you guys so much see
you oh and hook up my pops wine Tex comm
if you drink wine and you buy it on the
internet or at a [ __ ] supermarket
and you're overpaying for it go to wine
text comm and sign up for my dad's
service it means a lot to me and it's
been a lot of fun I'm enjoying that as
well so see you later
you